we're broken
trying desperately to keep ourselves
going by pretending we're not
we must remember the lives we've lost
this stuff looks incredible hey guys
pete here this will be my breakdown of
the official teaser for the expanse
season 6. they dropped this yesterday at
the new york city comic con virtual
panel and as i mentioned in my video on
that it's one of those it's the final
season so we want to get you hyped up
but we don't want to give anything away
kind of teasers it's short it looks
amazing and if you've read the sixth
book you can mostly put together what's
happening of course i've done that but
the plan is to discuss what we see in
this trailer in the most spoiler-free
way possible so i won't be giving away
any big secrets there's also some really
nice looking season six still photos so
let's jump in look at this photo of
drummer and look at how far they've come
in six seasons in pretty much every
aspect of the craft behind making this
show i was looking at these photos and
the different shots in the trailer and
thinking about the world they've created
it's come to life it's a place it feels
plausible and looks lived in and now i
can't see this stuff without thinking
that someone is going to go and take all
these sets down or possibly they've
already been cleared out the end is
coming and with this first bit of
footage it's officially in motion along
with the teaser they released the
official season six description it says
the sixth and final season of the
expanse picks up with the solar system
at war as marco anaros and his free navy
continued to launch devastating asteroid
attacks on earth and mars as the
tensions of war and shared loss
threatened to pull the crew of the
rasanante apart christian abbasarala
makes a bold move and sends former
martian marine bobby draper on a secret
mission that could turn the tide
meanwhile in the belt drummer and what's
left of her family are on the run and
hunted for betraying marco and on a
distant planet beyond the rings a new
power begins to rise this mostly matches
up with the talking points that they
brought to the comic-con panel which
i've already discussed in the other
video but i thought it's worth looking
at here because it does add context to
everything we see
the teaser opens with holden pushing a
button which i sincerely hope is a nod
to one of my favorite lines in the books
he's on the rossi he's sitting in the
pilot's chair and he yells everyone
brace and then you see the drive light
up one thing you don't see in this
trailer is bull and it's not clear
what's happening here it's very unlikely
that holden would be taking over the
piloting duties for alex since that's
not something he knows how to do this is
probably an emergency and we see
everyone's in suits and if all these
shots are connected then we see the
others hitting the deck there's a quick
shot of the rossi doing maneuvers with a
lot of pdc fire and then it cuts to the
tynan getting lit up with drummer in a
suit in the pilot's chair there's this
shot where you can see that the hull has
a lot of holes blown through it and what
looks like drummer slumped over in the
chair i highly doubt that this is the
end of her story if for no other reason
then why would they show that in the
opening seconds of a quick teaser it's
almost as if they want you to believe
that the rossi found themselves in a
situation where it was her or them and
to me it all feels like misdirection
what you can take away from this for
sure is that there are going to be some
exciting space battles and it looks like
everyone will be involved after that
there's a shot of earth in new york city
you can see the sky is dark there's
smoke rising from the skyline and that
most of the city is still underwater
from the sea walls failing in season
five after the rocks hit you hear abba
sarah say we're broken trying
desperately to keep ourselves going by
pretending we're not we see her looking
at a data pad sitting there deep in
thought holding a naomi strapping in and
a shot of amos thinking wearing a suit
and turning to look at the rasanante
plaque that's cut with her continuing
saying that we must remember the lives
we've lost
so in the comic-con panel they mentioned
that the earth had been totally
obliterated by the free navy's asteroid
attack that part wasn't really clear at
the end of last season after nancy gal's
death abasarallah is back in charge and
that means that she's gonna be dealing
with the aftermath there's a scene here
where she's walking into a room with un
body bags stacked on top of each other
and then a sequence with bobby taking
fire in her power armor and from the sky
overhead it looks like she's in the slow
zone and then a shot of clarissa
grimacing grabbing her head on the rossi
and you see that the voice over is
coming from abu sarah talking to someone
on the surface of earth so the first
half is bullets flying the earth dying
and most of the characters sitting
around thinking looking like they're on
the verge of crying we transitioned to
the second half with a quick burst of
action shots there's more space battle
shots with the pella firing torpedoes an
explosion that looks like it's on a
station those continued asteroid attacks
on earth from orbit from the free navy
and then the focus shifts to marco who
we know is responsible for all of this
chaos from the graffiti you get the idea
that some of the belters are getting
behind him and then there's this shot on
series where it looks like he's getting
ready to address a crowd who seemed to
be cheering him on you see him hand fill
up a gun and then in a different shot he
says you and i were meant to be out here
in the darkness in the fight that's who
we were born to be while he's talking we
see them at their battle stations on the
pela and then another sequence of
drummer firing a gun then there's a
couple of intriguing shots from laconia
you get a much better look at the
orbital platforms that were left behind
from the gate builders we saw those in
the closing moments of season five and
here again you can't miss that blue glow
inside after that we see a young girl
walking and it's through the lens that
resembles some of the shots from season
four that involve the investigator and
the final shot is the rossi spinning
with its point defense cannons firing on
something that explodes nearly engulfing
the ship there was a shot earlier that
looked like rocks flying through space
and i think that might be what they're
shooting at here from what we see it
looks like the current conflict is going
to be taking a toll on everyone and
they'll be dealing with it or acting out
because of it in different ways marco's
coming off his biggest victory at the
end of last season and this makes it
looks like he starts out riding high
there's a lot we don't see here it's a
pretty tight focus on the core
characters which we mostly know where
they are a lot of the questions i have
about how this season's going to develop
come more from the characters outside
the inner circle like i said earlier
there's no bull in this we don't see any
monika there's really no shots of bobby
on the rossi instead we see her on earth
with abasarala and then later in the
slow zone and with fred johnson missing
there's really not much representation
for the belt outside of drummer who
really doesn't have any power at this
point marco can hold on to his gains if
earth is on the defensive but he has to
have allies to maintain order which
means we might meet a lot of new
characters
just to reiterate some of the details
from yesterday's video it has been
confirmed that there are only six
episodes in this final season the only
one they mentioned being longer than
usual was the finale with a run time of
65 minutes they're only doing book six
nothing from the final trilogy and then
they're adding some stuff on laconia
that comes from the novella strange dogs
i read an article in collider today
where ty frank was talking about it and
he said i think the thing that season
six does is it pays off the story that
we began in episode one of season one
where the martians the earthers and the
belters were all in this incredibly
uneasy and unstable political system
with the belters absolutely being the
foot of that table and everyone fighting
for their place in the solar system i
think we pay off that story in a very
satisfying way and we keep some of the
mystery intact involving the greater
forces of the universe that humans are
only starting to become aware if we want
to tell more stories there were a lot of
comments on my video with people who
were worried about the short season
which i get but just remember they did
do book three and seven normal length
episodes in the third season admittedly
i thought some of that felt rushed but
there's actually less to adapt from the
sixth book because of what they already
covered in season five i do think it's
doable and if they really nail it it
could turn out to be exhilarating i
think what people might find more
troubling is that part of his comment
talking about the greater forces of the
universe some people are going to be
pissed that there's no conclusion to the
gate builders and unknown aggressors
part of the story that is what it is i
mean they took three additional novels
to get into that and there's really no
number of episodes that you could tack
on to the end of this season to make
that work if we want to see that we just
have to hope that there'll be more
expanse in the future it's weird because
you can never really tell why they're
saying what they're saying when they
talk about things like the pause or if
they're throwing it out there if we want
to tell more stories you can't tell if
they're doing that because they have
something planned that they can't reveal
or if they're just doing that to try to
make it happen as a fan i tend to think
that there's something going on but then
i kind of have to pull myself back you
know i don't really know i just want to
see that stuff to this point i can say
that they've made hints but they've
definitely not confirmed anything and
that's really all there is to it a
couple other details the first episode
and only the first episode will premiere
on december 10th then they're going to
be released weekly which means that the
finale will air on january 14th so the
end of the expanse is coming and i think
that brings us to the end of this video
as well one more thing before i go i'm
not sure how i feel about this situation
where there's tension building with the
crew of the rossi i kind of see where
they're going but it also kind of feels
wrong in their last hurrah you know so
i'm interested to hear what you guys
think about that and how big of a part
of the season you think it'll turn out
to be so let me know in the comments
what you think about the teaser what you
think about all these announcements what
was your favorite shot and if you want
to talk book spoilers i'm all for it
just make sure you mark those so we
don't spoil it for everyone else please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon